hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his lecture what is metaphysics
Heidegger talks quite a bit about
anxiety which is a mood or attunement
and it's a fundamental one it's the one
which allows us best as human beings to
relate ourselves to this that's
fundamental metaphysical whatever we
want to call a principle reality thing
we have to take into account of the
nothing that Heidegger thinks has been
primarily overlooked throughout the
history of previous metaphysics in which
he's trying to bring to our attention in
an original way and he talks about what
he calls original anxiety as that which
places us in relation to the beings as
they are receding from us and the
nothing has us realized our place within
the totality of beings there's all of
that and I've talked about that in other
places here what we want to focus on is
the relationship between what he calls
original anxiety and the everydayness in
which we ignore or repress or find ways
to distract ourselves from this this
original anxiety so you know another way
of thinking about this is well if this
anxiety is so fundamental why aren't we
feeling it why aren't we registering it
not just effectively but cognitively in
our lives all the time and hide reduce
as well it's churning away under the
surface for most people but generally
it's repressed or we find ways to
distract ourselves from it so that we
don't feel it so that we don't think it
so that we don't experience it and
thereby don't have to deal with the
nothing and also by correlation don't
have to think in terms of the fullness
of our freedom or you know other things
that are going along with that even the
notion of selfhood or he doesn't use the
term here but he will in many other
places authenticity so if we realize
what is really what is going on not just
within beings as a totality but also in
ourselves as design
as being there as being held out into
the nothing we are going to experience
that through anxiety
Heidegger talks about ways in which we
we can evade this distraction he's going
to detail a number of different modes of
distracted nough sin being in time and
what this produces is a distorted or
even an eclipsed view of the nothing
there is no nothing that's being paid
attention to instead what we have is a
preoccupation with beings so you know
I'll just give you a few examples of
what this might look like even though he
doesn't provide these here in what is
metaphysics one thing that Heidegger
does talk about in being in time is what
he calls empty chatter you know this
constant chattering about you know
things that are rather ephemeral not
very important we might think of a large
part of social media today as
exemplifying what Heidegger calls empty
chatter you know the obsession with
celebrities and what they're up to
the listicles that people put together
particularly if they're about
politicians or about you know
other types of if you think about it
politicians these days really are except
insofar as they do any actual work
celebrities right and that is one mode
of distracting ourselves from what's
really going on in our lives from what
really fundamentally matters and people
can do this you know over and over and
over again they're enabled by living in
a culture which constantly churns this
stuff out for them other ways could be
through you know various forms of
becoming obsessed with with you know a
particular region of beings losing
yourself as we say in that it could be
anything from collecting stamps to
collecting relationships to collecting
experiences right we could come up with
many other interesting examples but in
all cases there's sort of a
preoccupation with beings and a loss of
the grasp of be
itself and Heidegger tells us that in
you know anxiety something else is
happening he talks about this is
bewildered calm that that takes place on
our part and you know we don't see but
we we we can we grasp the nothing in
this so here we go a little bit further
on he says how is it then that we don't
feel this anxiety except in rare moments
he says we lose ourselves altogether
among beings in a certain way the more
we turn towards beings in our
preoccupations the less we let beings as
a whole
slip away as such and the more we turn
away from the nothing just as surely to
be hasten to the public super fifties
that is the you know little top areas of
existence so by allowing ourselves to be
dazzled or or brought in or seduced by
these regions of being the things at the
superficial level we lose our
possibility of grasping the depth and he
goes on into any trucks about the
anxiety still being there for us he's
got these beautiful you know very short
phenomenological analyses he says
anxiety is there it is only sleeping its
breath Quivers perpetually through
design only slightly in those who are
jitter ibly jittery imperceptibly in the
oh yes and oh no of men of affairs that
is people who are concerned with
business right whether that business be
running a university or canvassing for
votes or you know writing up little
things in social media whatever it is
the oh yes oh no no and then he says
most readily in the reserved and most
assuredly and those who are basically
daring Heidegger is not spelling this
out in any sort of thematic way here but
there's really two main you could say
ways in which anxiety breaks breaks out
and offers it
to us as design he talks about occasions
and then he talks about what we can call
comportment so the reserved and the
daring are two types of compartments or
ways in which we relate ourselves to the
world and we'll talk about those just in
just a moment let's talk about occasions
first so Heidegger says you don't need
any super special occasion you don't
actually have to go to somebody who
specializes in awakening Heidegger and
anxiety the way certain psychoanalysts
set themselves up to do or I suppose
there's probably some self-help gurus
out there doing that as well there's a
lot of people have made a lot of hay out
of Heidegger on this point he says
original anxiety can awaken in existence
at any moment it needs no unusual event
to rouse it its sway is as thorough
going as it's possible occasions
occasioning czar trivial it is always
ready
that would only seldom Springs and we
are snatched away and left hanging it's
a constant possibility for us we don't
need some sort of earth-shaking event in
order to spark this anxiety and to get
us feeling that it could be as trivial
as running out of cigarettes
and wondering should I still be smoking
I don't know I'm 40 years old and you
know that what does it mean to be 40
years old and this line of thinking and
eventually we have an existential crisis
right when we have an existential crisis
that is from a Haida garyun perspective
the anxiety coming to the fore and it
can happen through you know momentous
things like losing a job the death of a
loved one
the breakdown of a relationship finding
out that the political party that you
hitched your wagon to because you
thought they were going to produce
utopia on earth is left you and all your
compatriots in the dust those sorts of
things can can be big things but it can
be as simple as running out of shampoo
or looking out the window
seeing something that puzzles you or
having dinner with somebody who gives a
offhand remark that you then think about
so occasions open up you might say the
pores within the everyday through which
anxiety can intrude itself intrude
itself rightly because the anxiety is
more original than the everyday now we
also have these compartments right
Heidegger does not tell us that much
about the reserved but he does tell us
some things about the daring that are
quite interesting this might make us
think about the nature of creativity and
risk so Heidegger tells us ok those who
are basically daring he says those those
daring ones are sustained by that on
which they expend themselves they are
sustained by that on which they expend
themselves so if they're a musician it
is the music and the instrument and the
the audience that is listening to it if
they're artists you know working with
visual things if those means if it's all
sorts of other ways in which people are
daring you could be daring for example
in business this is what real
entrepreneurship is about about taking
risk about producing something new that
has genuine value not just hopping on a
trend and saying oh well such and such
as hot all you know slap a label on that
and you know regurgitate some business
school quotes and now I've got a product
that's that's not being Dearing that's
being safe being daring would be
something like I don't know saying that
philosophy could matter for ordinary
people and going out and doing it or
thinking that I'll take on a big
corporation because even though they
have all this power and in all these
people working for them they're not
fulfilling this need here that people
genuinely have or if we think about in
terms of Education throwing off some of
the shackles of modern educational
theory and getting back to what
education ought to be but not doing so
in a way that's only good for the elite
so we could come up with lots of
examples all of them involve
risk all of them involve an immersion in
what it is that you're being daring
about so he says the daring ones are
sustained right in order thus to
preserve the ultimate grandeur of
existence they are contributing
something to existence this is why we
are attracted to people who are
genuinely innovative not just the people
who talk about innovation or thought
leadership or stuff like that or do TED
Talks the people where we see it's the
real deal because they are what
Heidegger calls daring and he goes on
and he says the anxiety of those who are
daring now this might throw you wait a
second those who are daring don't they
proceed without anxiety no they proceed
through anxiety they proceed despite
anxiety they are engaged in what in
other places we call courage which does
not mean a lack of fear but a dealing
with the fear in some sort of reasonable
and and and necessary way in order to
attain something that is good and so he
says the anxiety of those who are daring
cannot be opposed to joy or even to the
comfortable enjoyment of tranquilized
muscle it stands outside all such
opposition in secret alliance with the
cheerfulness and gentleness of creative
longing we met a beautiful turn of
phrase it stands in secret alliance with
the cheerfulness and gentleness of
creative longing this is a comportment
that Heidegger thinks is one by which a
human being could be you know more
genuine more authentic because they are
more in touch with the anxiety that
pervades all of human existence its
original anxiety and they do things in
the world they don't just retreat from
the world even the reserves don't simply
retreat from the world the reserved are
you know engaged in saying this matters
not this the daring are doing something
a bit different they are bringing
something new and Heidegger uses that
word creative I think quite deliberately
so all of this is how original anxiety
can
be experienced and lived out
you